ah
[Música]
a
compañías de seguridad privadas
proveedores de servicios militares
contratistas operacionales eufemismos
empresas de mercenarios a sueldo acá en
eeuu como dyncorp de film international
twitter play canopy o vine al corp o lo
que antes era black a corporaciones
multinacionales que contratan
mercenarios de todo el mundo de hecho
sólo el 33 por ciento de contratistas
militares en afganistán son ciudadanos
estadounidenses empresas privadas que
entrenan ejércitos hacen inteligencia y
aprietan el gatillo y te han hecho el
número de hombres en terreno de
militares reduzca mientras que los
mercenarios a sueldo aumentan no tienen
que rendir cuentas además autoridades
según la revista the atlantic desde el
2009 la tasa de contratistas militares
estadounidenses en las zonas de guerra
aumentó de un escenario por un soldado a
tres mercenarios por un soldado algo que
preocupa a eeuu por la dependencia que
tienen en las guerras con las empresas
privadas de seguridad
en un país en el que un alto porcentaje
de la población pasa por lo menos tres
años de su vida en el ejército con todo
lo que ello conlleva
las historias de israelíes pagados para
cometer actos violentos o para entrenar
militarmente fuera de las fronteras del
país es tal vez sorprendentemente
pequeña sin embargo los casos de
mercenarios israelíes confesos o
conocidos han hecho mucho mucho ruido en
la prensa uno de ellos es el del ex
comandante y airplane quien en la década
de 1980 protagonizó un caso de
entrenamiento a paramilitares de extrema
derecha y narcotraficantes en colombia
lo que sí es más frecuente es que
israelíes que han servido en unidades de
élite del ejército una vez terminado su
servicio han han trabajado o trabajan o
crean empresas en las que ofrecen
servicios que caminan en la fina línea
de lo para legal ofreciendo servicios de
ciberespionaje o seguridad personal
sobre todo en países de latinoamérica
y
mercenarios de origen británico han
estado involucrados incluso en el plan
de asesinato del que fuera el jefe del
cartel de medellín pablo escobar
considerado entonces como uno de los
hombres más peligrosos y ricos de la
tierra en 1989 un comando liderado por
el escocés peter mcaleese fue contratado
dice él por el cartel de cali para
asesinar a escobar en su hacienda de
nápoles el plan nunca se cumplió porque
el helicóptero en el que viajaba tuvo un
accidente en 2004 otro reconocido
mercenario simon mann estuvo involucrado
en el intento de golpe de estado en
guinea ecuatorial en el que también
estuvo involucrado mark tacher el hijo
de la ex primera ministra británica
también otros mercenarios de origen
británico estuvieron involucrados en la
guerra civil en la ncaa una empresa de
seguridad privada
dio entrenamiento especializado a una
fuerza elite de la policía de ese país
que estaba luchando contra los tigres de
liberación de la tierra del tamil por
este hecho esas personas están siendo
investigadas por la policía metro
por crímenes de guerra y violación de
los derechos humanos
[Música]